all right Jeffrey Epstein's apparent
suicide has led to wide speculation and
theories about how he died the disgraced
financier his body was found inside his
Manhattan jail cell one source tells CBS
News Epstein hanged himself CBS News has
reported many times on Americans
long-standing fascination with alleged
conspiracies
it seems fewer and fewer Americans
believe the official US government
accounted the assassination that Lee
Harvey Oswald murdered the President and
probably acted alone those are charged a
conspiracy is being carried on by
scientists and the military to cover up
visitations from outer space use that
charge to explain why no UFOs have been
reported by our space defense system the
Elvis lives controversy got going in
earnest with publication of a picture a
fan took at Graceland after Presley's
funeral now you saw Elvis we're in the
grocery store in Vicksburg mitigant
that's not a conspiracy that's true he's
born
other than that right there and what
role does the internet play in fueling
them psychiatrist dr. sue Varma is here
with some ideas on the one hand we live
at a time when there is more information
available at our fingertips and at any
other time but on the other it seems
that so many of us turn to information
that confirms our wildest imaginations
why yes so uncertainty produces a lot of
anxiety for people and conspiracy
theories are one way that our brain is
trying to cope with it and in fact we
see that the fear centers in the brain
the amygdala tries to go into analytic
overdrive and it takes the same amount
of limited information and keeps
churning in and processing new
narratives and that's why we can see
conspiracy theories 50 years after event
has happened on some level though we
have to believe it though don't we sue
for them to flourish we have to believe
it yes and this is what we call
confirmatory bias and that our brain
seeks information that it already
believes and it also seeks information
from other people that we trust and
nowadays we're finding that news is
coming from our peers from our friends
we're getting it from social media and
there isn't this top-down effect there's
more of a sort of democratic approach to
seeking information even if it's
misinformation our brain wants
roll it wants a sense of safety it wants
to fill in the gaps and it's looking
everywhere it possibly can to do that
there are certain people more prone to
believe in conspiracy theories you know
this is such an interesting theory so we
used to believe that it was people who
are marginalized who were on the fringes
who are isolated who perhaps had a lot
of time to go down these rabbit holes
but we're finding more and more that 50%
of Americans believe in at least in one
conspiracy theory and get this if you
believe in one you're more likely to
believe in others yeah are there certain
circumstances where conspiracy theories
flourish do something have to be going
on yes and it's usually during periods
of high stress and trauma when there's
something emotionally charged happening
and it could be anything from terrorism
to an economic recession to a death a
suicide think things were there's
questions that remain to be unanswered
and that make us feel very unsettled
that's really the hallmark of this some
conspiracy theories a pretty harmless
they're kind of like sci-fi you engage
with you know I have a couple drinks
talk about what if but on the other hand
there are some dangerous ones out there
right where you would like to change
people's minds if you could so what what
can you do with the the proverbial crazy
uncle at your dinner table to change
their mind you know here's the thing
you're gonna have a really difficult
time and ask yourself what's the
cost-benefit analysis right if it's a
loved one and you really need to engage
them that's what this is about is making
them feel like they have a seat at the
table do that in whatever way that you
can maybe on a political level they
don't feel like they have a voice but
it's about somebody trying to create
agency in their life so are there ways
that you can reintegrate them into the
family can you involve them in
conversations can you give them
something to do around the house around
the dinner table can you make them feel
meaningful and valued because that's
that's what this is about
whatever you provide the facts those who
provide the facts and say look this
isn't true yes how do you deal with that
they're gonna be butting heads I have to
say that this is for many many people a
lose-lose situation because you already
believe very firmly look I'm not saying
that this is bordering you know delusion
as we talked about in psychiatry which
is a firm fixed unshakable belief the
truth of the reality is that if
depending on where you grew up if you
grew up in a society the way there was a
lot of corruption these things to you or
fact if you grew up in a home or
mistrust with something or that you
blamed Authority or that you were
suspicious of officials you are going
have a really hard time getting this
person the Internet and the social media
have really complicated this haven't
they yes and conspiracy theory isn't
about fact is about where we give
attention or and our attention is drawn
to things that we already believe in and
so you're really gonna have a hard time
so the best thing that you can do is
limit it present them with facts give
them information but they have to be
willing to change their way of thought
all right sue sounds like a big job
somebody thank you very much sue bomber
for joining us this morning